[Music]
we're talking about your family your
brothers you guys like to mess with each
other what's what's the meanest prank
that your brothers have played on you
mmm Wow so many no because in most
families your I would be the baby and my
family I'm the victim because there's 20
27 comedian so I you know the babies who
did gets picked on the meanest thing
they ever did i Emmys the Emmys the
award show the Emmys Emmys award show
one year we was going to the Emmys and
we is all gonna present together me Sean
Kane and Damon and you know I they was
like they went about these like $2,500
suits and I was like dude I just did Mo
Money I spending $2,500 on a suit you
know that's right
and it was like stop being cheap you
know and I was like cheap I just don't
want to do that you know 19 years old
I'd rather spend that money on you know
like good stuff like a car I could buy
like you know weed or something with
that you know I could fill my fridge
like the dr. Dre video with 40 ounces
and you know yeah and so my brothers was
like stop being cheap so I was like okay
fine I was like okay how about this
how about I go rent a tux and you guys
wear the expenses offense the tux and
I'll come out with a really small tux
like her go now come running out and
then I got had this whole thing I was
gonna do and they go yeah that sounds
like a good thing so you were like a
sketch for them I bought a whole sketch
I gave him paper it's not like I came to
get us and my brother Shawn looked at me
they came to get us
and I said Shawn there's gonna be funny
right he goes yeah and then he gave me
the kiss of death
right on my lips he said I love you
Marlon and we went out they went out and
they go hey they and they call me out
they go and now welcome away his
brothers my brother's go hey where's
Marlon I come running out in this little
suit and I got my shoes on two left feet
and I got these big socks on I look like
Oracle on crackers like hey guys and my
brother said and the nominees are
no sketch no no I never sweat so hard
and I was like instant sweat like you
gotta be kidding me and they just start
cracking up on the seat and they just
start saying the nominees and I'm like
oh snap I think I cursed I was just so
messed up
so afterward you know they was mad at me
and it took a minute but you know they
didn't we I forgave him but his thing
I'm paid a ass back how you gonna do
that I'm the youngest they're gonna go
first I'm burying them in the Emmys oooh
they are all gonna be in their casket
with arms and take pictures with that
and go in you tweeted something recently
I have to ask you about you tweeted
about UFC fighter Ronda Rousey and you
said you what was it you said that you
wanted to you have sort of a fixation
with her oh you wanted to smell her
training gloves and feet raps did you
tweet that yeah but here's why you
either did or you didn't you were sort
of like where are you getting this Conan
and then suddenly it went to yeah well
here's the thing I say that in a good
way cuz you know and all this this
pheromones and those gloves and feet
reps and I have a crush on her I think
she's dope but we have a picture of her
actually wailing away on someone and so
that's just sexy ain't it yeah ggressive
she is just this is something about a
woman that could kick your behind this
is just something sexy about I want to
leave it late lolly just punch me in the
face right I want her to like take me
and like she cuz she does his moves you
would have beaten by a woman is what
you're saying
well just something professionally
though professionally
so listen I want to wrestle the round
one i what i 100 I got a fantasy man I
want a wrestle around with her and she
tapped makes people tap out yeah and
like just like three minutes he makes
him tap out cuz she grabbed the arm and
she breaks it back yeah I want her to
grab my penis and just grab it and you
won't have to tap out she'll know
anything
[Applause]
you broke our show we had a
semi-legitimate show until you came you
started it no I did not you asked me two
questions I don't know I don't remember
hey Conan to kick his own ass